واضح انه وزير الخارجي على الاقل انا يعني
ممكن ان اؤكد الخارجيه وهو يستمع لاحد
المسؤولين
لاحد المسؤولين
نعم يستمع لاحد المسؤولين في موقع الانقاذ
ربما لايجاز حول عمليات الانقاذ التي تتم
في هذه الساعات ومنذ ايام وهو يقترب اكثر
يبدو انهم ابلغوا ان هناك طفله ما زالت
على قيد الحياه ويقترب اكثر
للموقع
للاطلاع على سير عمليات الانقاذ التي تجري
في
منطقه كهرمان مرعش وايضا في باقي المناطق
كما قلت ان هناك يعني جولات متواليه
للوزراء ياتون الى هذا نعم هو وزير
الخارجيه بالفعل وزير الخارجيه التركي يصل
لهذا الموقع يصل الى النقطه التي يحاولون
اخراج منها الطفله عائشه
والتي كنا نرصدها منذ نحو ساعتين نايف
ويستمع الى عمال الانقاذ
يعطونه ايجازا حول عمليه الانقاذ التي تتم
الان وهي جوله دابا عليها المسؤولون
الاتراك خلال الايام الماضيه في منذ ان
ضرب الزلزال جنوب البلاد للاطلاع على ظروف
المتضررين وايضا على
سير عمليات الانقاذ في المناطق المنكوبه
يعني طيله الايام الماضيه المسؤولون
الاتراك يتعهدون
بمواصله هذه الاعمال وتامين
كل مستلزمات المتضررين وتعهدوا ايضا
باعاده الاعمار خلال عام وتامين منازل
للمتضررين خلال سنه
وتامين ايضا مبالغ ماليه للاسر تصل الى 15
الف ليره تركيه اي يعني نحو 1000 دولار
نايف لكل عائله متضرره
الان في هذه الاوليه يقومون بتامين منازل
متنقله
الان يغادر وزير الخارجيه الموقع
يغادر وزير الخارجيه الموقع صحيح اذا
تابعنا واياكم مشاهدي
وهي مركز الزلزال واكثر المناطق تضررا
نايف في